alors viens quand un pays croient comme
l'a noté que la population voit là et
qu'on a davantage de téléphones
cellulaires
on a besoin numéro de téléphone on les
trouve où on doit créer de nouveaux
indicatifs régionaux et là vous imaginez
on venait tout juste de sa mission qu à
3,8 à montréal au drame à prendre
d'hôtes ou 9 05 autour de toronto ap 05
exactement où il ya là plusieurs mois
vous êtes sorti derrière le téléphone à
roulettes imaginez-vous tellement
plaisant vous savez puis sur l'a9 y
rouler savais même pas que du saut vous
j'ai connu cela
oui on avait un bon téléphone jaune
l'accroché mais où il me rappelle de ça
vous l'avez dit téléphonie cellulaire
c'est en augmentation il ya plus du
numéro de téléphone si bien qu'on a
épuisé les indicatifs régionaux c'est le
crtc des rats qui l'annoncé sur son site
alors problème discal peut créer on y va
québec est du québec savoir est séparée
et puis franchement il ya des indicatifs
régionaux que je ne connaissais pas est
ce que vous connaissez le 3 6 6 7
la région de québec en moi non plus
qu'attendu et évidemment les 5 8 ans
également 3 6e ça respirait et
maintenant banlieue de montréal
alors il ya 4 5 0 oui le 5 7 9 on va
ajouter le 3 5 4
maintenant à montréal 5 est évidemment
le cas 3,8 j'en suis il faut ajouter le
2 6 3 et pour l'ouest du québec
maintenant le 8h09 notamment à gatineau
le 8 sept rôles je ne connaissais pas il
faut ajouter le 4 6 8 à l'extérieur
également du québec mettra pour le
nouveau brunswick à partir de novembre
le 4 2 8 se rajouter aux 5 06 et à
terre-neuve en mai 2022 on va ajouter le
8 7 9 également lorsqu'on ajoute un
indicatif régional selon une étude on
ajoute 7 millions de numéros de
téléphone alors donc ça vaut la peine
et en terminant vous devez rapidement
entre 2017 et 2018
augmentation de la téléphonie cellulaire
du nombre d'abonnés 4,8 pour cent alors
vraiment on est rendu à peu près à quoi
33 millions d'abonnés au canada pour une
population de un peu moins de 38
ça fait du téléphone ça les amis oui
quelques téléphones il reste encore deux
ou trois facs aussi qui sont branchés
des ligues duras là aussi très bien
merci âge est aussi prêt page est
[Musique]